.
WE'LL SEE HOW THIS PLAYS OUT,
BUT THERE SHOULD DEFINITELY BE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> LET'S LOOK AHEAD.
YOUR SENIOR SENATOR FROM TEXAS,
JOHN CORNYN, HE'S TAKING THE
LEAD FOR LEGISLATION ON GUN
LEGISLATION.
ONE OPTION BEING DISCUSSED IS A
RED FLAG LAW.
I'M SURE YOU KNOW RICK SCOTT
ACTUALLY SIGNED ONE INTO LAW
WHEN HE WAS FLORIDA GOVERNOR
AFTER THE PARKLAND SHOOTING.
WOULD YOU VOTE YES ON A NATIONAL
RED FLAG LAW?
>> NO, I WOULDN'T.
YOU KNOW, IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE
RICK SCOTT SIGNED THE LAW.
YOU WOULD THINK FROM THE TROLLS
ON THE INTERNET THAT I'M THE
NUMBER ONE ADVOCATE FOR RED FLAG
LAWS.
THAT'S A BIT OF A MYTH
PERPETUATED BY MY OWN SIDE.
NOW, TRUTHFULLY, I THINK THERE'S
A LOT OF PROBLEMS WITH RED FLAG.
ESPECIALLY AT A NATIONAL LEVEL.
WHEN IT COMES TO CRIMINAL LAW,
THAT REALLY SHOULD BE
DEMOCRATICALLY DECIDED AT THE
LOCAL AND STATE LEVEL, BUT EVEN
SO --
>> SO WOULD YOU SUPPORT WITH
UN -- WOULD YOU SUPPORT A RED
FLAG LAW IN TEXAS?
>> THE WELL, NO.
HERE'S WHY, BECAUSE WE ARE
ESSENTIALLY TRYING TO DO WITH
THE RED FLAG LAW IS ENFORCE THE
LAW BEFORE THE LAW HAS BEEN
BROKEN.
THAT'S A REALLY DIFFICULT THING
TO DO.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO ASSESS WHETHER
SOMEBODY IS A THREAT.
IF THEY'RE SUCH A THREAT THEY'RE
THREATENING SOMEBODY WITH A
WEAPON ALREADY, THEY HAVE
ALREADY BROKEN THE LAW SO WHY DO
YOU NEED THE NEXT LAW?
THAT'S THE QUESTION CRITICS
RIGHTFULLY ASK ABOUT THIS.
ULTIMATELY, HOW THEY EVEN SOLVE
THE PROBLEM.
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE THESE THINGS
HAVE TO BE REPORTED FOR THEM TO
ACTUALLY MATTER.
YOU KNOW, AND IN THIS CASE, YOU
HAVE A TROUBLED TEENAGER WHO DID
SOME VERY STRANGE THINGS.
SHOOTING AT PEOPLE WITH BB GUNS,
CUTTING HIMSELF, SAYING CRAZY
THINGS.
DOES THIS REACH THE LEVEL WHERE
YOU INVOLUNTARILY COMMIT HIM OR
TAKE HIS PROPERTY?
BECAUSE THE THING IS, THOSE --
THOSE THINGS THIS TEENAGER WAS
DOING COULD BE APPLIED TO QUITE
A FEW TEENAGERS.
>> RIGHT.
THERE'S A BIG GULF, ANYBODY
WOULD ARGUE, BETWEEN COMMITTING
SOMEBODY AND ALLOWING HIM TO BUY
A WEAPON OF WAR, LEGALLY IN
TEXAS.
I MEAN, AND IF YOU CHANGE THE
LAW --
>> THIS GETS TO A SOLUTION --
>> OKAY.
>> SO, MAYBE THE SOLUTION WE
COULD AGREE ON IS IMPROVING OUR
BACKGROUND CHECK SYSTEM.
LOOK, AGAIN, HE WENT THROUGH A
BACKGROUND CHECK.
THE PROBLEM ISN'T THAT A RED
FLAG LAW COULD HAVE SOLVED THIS.
IT DOESN'T SEEM CLEAR THAT WOULD
HAVE HAPPENED.
THE PROBLEM IS THE BACKGROUND
CHECK DIDN'T CAPTURE THE FULL
STORY OF THIS PERSON.
SO, LOOK, REPUBLICANS ARE THE
ONES THAT PROPOSED AND PASSED
THE FIX ACT.
WHICH FURTHER IMPROVES THE
SYSTEM.
IT WAS THE NRA THAT ADVOCATED
FOR BACKGROUND CHECKS IN THE
FIRST PLACE BECAUSE, LOOK, GUN
OWNERS DO WANT --
>> WOULD YOU EXPAND THE
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS?
>> NO.
THAT MEANS I CAN NO LONGER SELL
A GUN TO MY FRIEND.
IF MY NEIGHBOR DARIN LET'S SAY
HER HUSBAND IS GONE FOR THE WEEK
AND SHE WANTS TO BORROW MY GUN,
THAT WOULD MAKE US BOTH FELONS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS.
THE PEOPLE LEAST LIKELY TO
ADHERE TO UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS ARE THE CRIMINALS WHO
INTEND HARM.
IT'S AN OUTCOME PROBLEM.
>> I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE SO
MANY REAL WORLD SCENARIOS THAT
ARE HARD TO POLICE, SO TO SPEAK.
WHAT ABOUT THE GUN SHOW
LOOPHOLE, THAT'S A VERY REAL
SITUATION THAT HAPPENS --
>> THAT'S THE SAME THING AS THE
UNIVERSAL --
>> PEOPLE BUY A GUN AT -- WELL,
NO, NO, IT'S A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE.
IF YOU'RE AT A GUN SHOW AND YOU
BUY A GUN, YOU BUY A GUN, SHOULD
THERE BE A BACKGROUND CHECK
INVOLVED IN THAT PURCHASE?
>> WELL, THERE IS.
THERE'S NOTHING PARTICULAR ABOUT
GUN SHOWS THERE'S A LOOPHOLE
FOR.
WHEN PEOPLE SAY THE GUN SHOW
LOOPHOLE, THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
PRIVATE TRANSFERS.
THERE'S NOTHING SPECIFIC IN LAW
ABOUT A GUN SHOW THAT ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO DO MORE THINGS THAN
THEY WOULD OTHERWISE BE ABLE TO
DO.
DEALERS AT GUN SHOWS MAKE YOU GO
THROUGH A BACKGROUND CHECK IF
YOU BUY A GUN.
>> LET'S -- CONGRESSMAN, LET'S
GET TO A COUPLE OF OTHER ISSUES
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY
POTENTIAL SOLUTIONS.
I WANT TO HEAR OTHER ONES YOU
POTENTIALLY AGREE WITH.
ONE IS, RAISE THE MINIMUM AGE TO
PURCHASE A FIREARM TO 21 YEARS
OLD.
THE SHOOTER IN UVALDE WAS ONLY
18.
THE BUFFALO SHOOTER WAS 18.
SANDY HOOK SHOOTER WAS 20 YEARS
OLD.
PARKLAND WAS 19 YEARS OLD.
SHOULD YOU BE 21 TO BUY A GUN?
>> WELL, I THINK THE QUESTION WE
HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES SHOULD 21
BE THE AGE YOU'RE AN ADULT?
AS A SOCIETY WE DO HAVE TO
DECIDE WHEN YOU'RE TECHNICALLY
AN ADULT.
>> SHOULD IT BE?
>> RIGHT NOW WE -- I'M NOT VERY
IMPRESSED BY OUR CURRENT SWATH
OF 18-YEAR-OLDS AND THEIR
MATURITY LEVEL SO MAYBE WE
SHOULD HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
BUT THEN IT HAS TO APPLY
BROADLY.
IT HAS TO MEAN YOU'RE NOT AN
ADULT UNTIL 21.
YOU KNOW, WHAT HAPPENS THEN WHEN
WE SEE A 22-YEAR-OLD COMMIT AN
ATROCITY, ARE WE GOING TO RAISE
IT AGAIN AND RAISE IT AGAIN?
AT A CERTAIN POINT WE HAVE TO
ASK OURSELVES WHAT OUR LIMITING
PRINCIPLE IS AS FAR AS AGE
BECAUSE TRUTHFULLY THE VAST
MAJORITY --
>> THE TEENAGE BRAIN ISN'T
FINISHED DEVELOPING UNTIL
MID-20s.
THERE'S MEDICAL STUDIES THAT
SHOW THE TEENAGE BRAIN ISN'T
FULLY DEVELOPED.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
AND DOES THAT MEAN THAT WE -- I
THINK IT'S 26, ACTUALLY.
SO, DOES THAT MEAN YOU'RE NOT AN
ADULT UNTIL 26?
I THINK I WAS ON MY SECOND
DEPLOYMENT BY THEN.
SO, YOU KNOW, IT'S -- THESE ARE
HARD QUESTIONS.
AND WE'RE GRASPING FOR AN
ANSWER.
>> THEY ARE HARD QUESTIONS.
>> TO AN ATROCITY THAT --
>> CONGRESSMAN, I MEAN, I
THINK -- I'M GUESSING THERE ARE
A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE
WATCHING THIS, HEARING YOU SAY
NO TO A LOT OF THE SOLUTIONS
THAT PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT.
SO, WHAT I WANT -- WHAT PEOPLE
TO KNOW IS, WHAT IS THE
SOLUTION?
WHAT WOULD YOU AGREE WITH?
THE WAY THE ANSWERS ARE COMING
OUT NOW IS NOTHING'S GOING TO
CHANGE.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE HERE IN
THIS COMMUNITY AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WANT TO HEAR THAT AFTER
THEIR BABIES ARE BEING MASSACRED
BY THESE GUNS.
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT NEEDS TO
CHANGE IS THE THINGS THAT WOULD
HAVE THE MOST IMMEDIATE AND
SUCCINCT EFFECT AND TANGIBLE
EFFECT ON THESE THINGS.
THAT'S SLUL SECURITY AT A
SCHOOL.
IT'S NOT AS IF REPUBLICANS HAVE
NOT -- I WENT THROUGH SOME
EARLIER, THE 21st CENTURY FIX
NICK ACT WHICH IS A NEW
PROPOSAL, LOOKING AT THE STOP
VIOLENCE IN SCHOOLS ACT.
THAT ONE ACTUALLY PUT RESOURCES
TOWARDS SCHOOLS, TOWARDS SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICERS, INCREASING
THE PENALTIES FOR STRAW
FIREARMS.
>> WHY NOT DO BOTH?
WHY ARE THEY MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE?
>> NONE OF THESE --
>> OTHER SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE TO
DO WITH ACCESS TO GUNS IN A WAY
THAT RESPECTS --
>> BECAUSE THE POLICIES --
>> THE SECOND AAMENDMENT AND ITS
CORE AND WHAT IT WAS INTENDED
AS?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY THE PROBLEM
WITH IT.
A LOT OF THESE POLICIES THAT I
THINK THE DEMOCRATS OFTEN
PROPOSE THAT ARE GUN CONTROL
POLICIES, THEY DO TWO THINGS.
ONE, THEY INFRINGE ON THE RIGHTS
OF MILLION AND MILLIONS OF GUN
OWNERS.
TWO, THEY PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE
THE OUTCOME YOU'RE HOPING FOR.
IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET THE
BENEFIT YOU WANT BUT IT'S GOING
TO COME AT GREAT COST, IT
GENERALLY MEANS IT'S NOT A VERY
GOOD POLICY.
>> HOW CAN YOU BE SO SURE?
>> IT SHOULD BE FAIRLY EASY
TO -- WELL, WE CAN LOOK AT DATA.
WE COULD HAVE DISCUSSION FOR A
WHILE.
BUT THE CO-RELATION BETWEEN GUN
OWNERSHIP AND GUN VIOLENCE IS
NOT VERY STRONG.
IT'S NOT AS STRONG AS A LOT OF
PEOPLE TEND TO BELIEVE IT IS.
YOU HAVE STATES LIKE NEW
HAMPSHIRE AND MIDWESTERN STATES
THAT HAVE VERY LAX --
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE SAYING
GUNS ARE NOT A PROBLEM?
300 SOME MILLION PEOPLE AND 400
MILLION GUNS.
YOU DON'T SEE THAT AS A PROBLEM?
>> NO.
CULTURALLY WE'RE A COUNTRY THAT
HAS LONG HAD A SECOND AMENDMENT
THAT BELIEVES IN THE RIGHT OF
SELF-DEFENSE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S A PROBLEM
THAT I OWN GUNS.
AND I KNOW THAT IF I DESTROYED
ALL MY GUNS, IT WOULD HAVE ZERO
EFFECT ON CRIME.
IT WOULD HAVE ZERO EFFECT ON GUN
HOMICIDE BECAUSE I'M NOT THE
PERSON WHO GOES AND SHOOTS
SOMEBODY.
I AM A PERSON WHO MIGHT PROTECT
SOMEBODY FROM BEING SHOT.
THE OTHER THING THAT GETS LEFT
OUT OF THIS, THIS IS A CDC
STUDY.
CDC FOUND THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CASES A YEAR WHERE
SOMEBODY USED A GUN TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES OR PROTECT OTHERS.
>> WELL, THERE WERE 19 PEOPLE --
THERE WERE 19 PEOPLE WHO WERE
HIGHLY TRAINED IN THE HALLWAY
AND THEY DIDN'T -- THEY COULDN'T
SAVE THESE CHILDREN.
>> DHAETS A PROBLEM RIGHT THERE
SDMRU MENTIONED THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
>> IT IS A PROBLEM.
EVERYBODY AGREES ON THAT.
NO QUESTION.
THE SECOND AMENDMENT CALLS FOR A
WELL-REGULATED MILITIA.
DO YOU REALLY THINK THE FOUNDING
FATHERS WHEN THEY WROTE
WELL-REGULATED MILITIA INTENDED
FOR ENOUGH GUNS AND WEAPONS OF
WAR THAT YOU ARE SO HIGHLY
TRAINED IN USING SHOULD BE USED
TO MASSACRE CHILDREN?
>> WELL, THERE'S MORE TO THE
SECOND AMENDMENT THAN WHAT YOU
JUST READ.
THERE'S A COMMA AFTER THAT.
SO, THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT IDEAS
IN THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
THERE'S THE INDIVIDUAL RIGHT TO
OWN A GUN AND THE RIGHT OF THE
PEOPLE TO HAVE A WELL-REGULATED
MILITIA.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE WEAPONS OF
WAR THING FOR A SECOND BECAUSE
YOU BROUGHT THAT UP.
HAVING BEEN TO WAR AND HAVING
USED MANY, MANY WEAPONS OF WAR,
I DON'T REALLY CLASSIFY THESE
RIFLES AS WEAPONS OF WAR.
WE USE THEM BUT THEY'RE MORE A
SELF-DEFENSE WEAPON.
I WOULD SAY IF A SEALE TEAM OR
INFANTRY TEAM GOES ON OFFENSE,
THEY'RE USING MUCH BIGGER
WEAPONS THAT ARE NOT AVAILABLE
TO YOUR COMMON CIVILIAN.
WE USE OUR M-4s, WHICH ARE AR
TYPE OF WEAPON FOR CLOSE
QUARTERS TYPE OF COMBAT.
BY THE WAY, THEY HAVE
CAPABILITIES THAT YOUR CIVILIAN
RIFLES DO NOT.
THESE ARE STILL SEMI-AUTOMATIC
RIFLES.
IN THE MILITARY WE HAVE
AUTOMATIC WEAPONS.
I WOULD SAY WE NEVER U